Hey
so bills retirement dinner next week are
you at Ana carpooling uh our Bayon Ana
gonna what are you and Ana gonna carpool
straight from work to Bill's retirement
dinner no but we actually broke up so oh
oh no probably not gonna carpool
right oh god I am so sorry man it's okay
I downloaded tinder last night I know
you're married cheaper just go on there
to see how you do right well anyway I
even filled out the profile yet but it's
there waiting good good for you man okay
you're processing and you're and you're
moving on and good all right she was my
everything
Yeah right you know we should go out you
know boys night out you mean Elliot but
not Elliot but like you and me we go out
we get some drinks we paint the town
look out ladies yeah yeah actually
tonight though
tonight is night market and let me tell
you about night market okay
so we do it every week but somehow it
manages to stay new what we do is my
wife and I we cook dinner a bunch of our
couple friends come over somebody brings
a bottle of wine and inevitably a
spontaneous game of charades breaks okay
well after that we go get drinks we're
kind of in bed early on school nights
you know boring married life yeah pretty
boring
so how's Anna I mean devastated we were
soul mates so I heard you and Kailyn
broke up yeah in it run its course you
don't all right or that's cream oh yeah
do you thank you
so that's why I'm gonna award the
nethers account to Kailyn you're giving
the adult toy account to Kailyn yeah
Kailyn is carefree he's playful who
better delete an account specializing in
toys for a
dull do you know what adult toys are
Natalie yeah I mean bikes for two gin
rummy billards anyway Anna I want you to
be second chair on this one a great
choice Natalie I really think Elliot is
going to be the perfect second chair on
this one actually said Anna not Elliot I
think we all know that Elliot would be
the perfect choice for the nethers
account no nobody thinks that great I'm
glad it's settled
welcome aboard Elliot hey sorry I took
your place on nethers I don't know why
Cailin thinks I'm some sort of sex
expert probably my Musk Galen is just
processing our breakup you guys broke up
yeah that's name Oh didn't didn't you
just meet your parents that was
regrettable but we all make mistakes big
mistakes but I can assure you it won't
affect our work we're both professionals
you know Anna call sex bedtime do you
know how confusing that is we're
actually talking about bills retirement
party right now right I can't even
believe he's retiring uh-huh
anna has this mole unlike the small of
her back and I've been taking pictures
of it to make sure it's not changing
shape
who's gonna monitor it now you know not
me Oh Kailyn can we talked sure
I wonder what the mole looks like Bill's
retirement party are you driving I need
a ride trying to get back together no I
just want to discuss remaining
professional in the workplace did I mean
anything to you
what please just pull yourself together
okay this job is important to me
cold as ice must be nice to not care
about anything huh oh you guys want a
car pull the bills retirement dinner
next week yes finally
I'm gonna miss bill we used to have cat
playdates every week next week we were
going to go to Legoland
you